قضى خمسين عاما في السجن منتظرا لحظه
اعدامه ارتكب جريمه مروعه في شبابه استدعت
حكم الاعدام لكنه امضى اكثر من نصف قرن في
البدله الحمراء ولم ياتي ذلك اليوم بعد
الاسم
التهمه قتل اربعه اشخاص
المكان اليابان
الحكم الاعدام
خمسه عقود قضاها هذا الملاكم الياباني خلف
القضبان حتى لقب بعميد سجناء العالم
المحكوم عليهم بالاعدام شنقا ايواءها
كماذا ولد في العاشر من شهر مارس عام
1936 في مدينه شيزوكا اليابانيه كان
ملاكما ناجحا في بدايه حياته واحتل
المرتبه السادسه في فئه وزن الريشه وانهى
مسيرته الرياضيه محققا ميداليات وارقاما
قياسيه لكن حياتهم انقلبت راسا على عقب
بعد ان انهى مسيرته في عالم الملاكمه وعمل
في احد المصانع في مدينه شيزوكا مسقط راسه
عام
1966 جاء العام الذي قلب حياته كمدى راسا
على عقب في 30 من يونيو من هذا العام
اندلع حريق ضخم في منزل رئيسه في العمل
بعد اخماد الحريق عثر على جثث رئيسه
وزوجته وطفليه لكن تبين انهم تعرضوا جميعا
للطعن وكان حكما منتظرا في موقع الجريمه
للمشاركه في اخماد الحريق بحسب اعترافاته
لاحقا حضرت الشرطه واستجوبتها كمادى ضمن
مجموعه من الاشخاص واستمرت فتره استجوابه
ل 2004 وستين ساعه على مدار 23 يوما حصلت
الشرطه على اعتراف منها كمدى بقتل الضحايا
كما عثر على بقايا من الدم والبنزين على
ملابس تعود لها لاحقا نفى المتهم
اعترافاته امام المحكمه وقال محاميه انه
تعرض للضرب والتهديد والحرمان من شرب
الماء ودخول الحمام لانتزاع الاعتراف قصرا
من موكله في سبتمبر من عام
1968 توصلت هيئه المحكمه الى انها كماده
مذنب وحكمت عليه بالاعدام وبعد الاستئناف
عيدت المحكمه العليا حكم الاعدام لازم
حكمادى القطبان والزنازين حتى 2004 عندما
تقدم بطلب لاعاده النظر في حكم الاعدام
لكنه قبل بالرد فيديكو شقيقه المتهم التي
واضبت على زيارته شهريا في محبسه طوال تلك
المده قالت انه رفض رؤيتها او رؤيه اي شخص
اخر وان قضاء ما يقرب من نصف قرن في
انتظار الموت دفعه الى الجنود
بعد اربع سنوات تقدمها ماذا بطلب استئناف
اخر فقرر القضاء اعاده المحاكمه لوجود
شكوك حول ادله الادانه ثم اطلق سراحه لكنه
حتى الان لم يحصل على البراءه
كماذا يبلغ من العمر اليوم 87 عاما يسير
في الشوارع بحريه غير مكتمله بعدما امرت
المحكمه العليا عام 2023 باعاده محاكمته
مجددا قرار نهائي سيكون مصيريا بالنسبه
لهكمادا فاما ان يسرعه الى حبل المشنقه
بعد سته عقود من الانتظار للحظه الموت او
يخلصه منها الى الابد
[موسيقى]